HE WILL BE OUT OF GOVERNMENT
WORK.
JOHN BOLTON IS THE NEXT NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR.
ANOTHER ROCKY RIDE FOR WALL
STREET.
DEIDRE BOLTON THIS ISUN
DEIDRE BOLTON THIS ISU
DEIDRE BOLTON THIS IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> THE DOW WAS DOWN 700 POINTS.
STILL IN THE RED BY 550 POINTS.
ALL 3 INDEXES LOWER BY AT LEAST
2% AND ALL LOWER FOR THE WEEK.
A COCKTAIL OF 3 KEY INGREDIENTS
HURT.
FIRST TRADERS FEAR A TRADE WAR
BETWEEN THE U.S. AND CHINA.
INDUSTRIAL STOCKS LIKE BOEING
AND DEER ALL DOWN BY MORE THAN
3%.
THERE IS TIME FOR CHINA AND THE
U.S. TO SIT DOWN TOGETHER AND
NEGOTIATE BEFORE A MAY DEADLINE.
INVESTORS ARE PRICING IN THE
WORST, WHICH IS AN ALL OUT TRADE
BIGGEST ECONOMIES.
THE MIXED MARCH JOBS REPORT
HURT.
FEWER JOBS ADDED THAN FORECAST.
INVESTORS IGNORED THE BRIGHT
SPOT OF 17 YEAR LOW EMPLOT.
POWELL TOOK QUESTIONS AND SAID
GRADUAL RATE HIKES WILL HELP THE
FED MAKE OF MEET ITS INFLATION
TARGET.
TRADERS HEARD I WILL HAVE TO PAY
MORE TO BORROW MONEY.
CHAIRMAN POWELL DID NOT TALK
ABOUT TRADE TENSIONS, BUT SAID
THAT TARIFFS EFFECT THE ECONOMY.
CONSUMERS AND BUSINESSES ARE
FORCED TO PAY MORE FOR IMPORTED
GOODS AND COSTS GO HIGHER.
THE FED MAY HAVE TO RAISE RATES
EVEN MORE TO KEEP INFLATIONARY
PRESSURES IN LINE.
MAKING ALL BORROWING MORE
EXPENSIVE.
TODAY WAS A RECIPE FOR SELLING